whoever is more confident wins when
you're hanging around somebody Whoever
has more confidence is going to be the
person who influences and persuades the
other person and this is for all areas
of your life if you're hanging around
people who are confident that you will
not be successful and you're lacking
confidence in your success guess what
their confidence in how unsuccessful
you're going to be will breed into you
and you'll feel like you can't do it on
the flip side if you're hanging around
people who believe in you who make you
feel amazing guess what their confidence
in you their belief in you will help you
believe more in yourself